je m'appelle ingrid franssen je suis
originaire de malmö en suède
je suis grande je suis blonde les yeux
bleus et j'ai 23 ans je suis célibataire
et j'adore sortir le soir et faire la
fête
oui je le savais ça allait provoquer
cette réaction
si j'avais envie d'attirer un très grand
nombre de personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux
si j'avais envie de me faire énormément
d'amis en très peu de temps notamment
chez les hommes n'est ce pas messieurs
c'est exactement comme ça que je me
prendrais c'est exactement de cette
façon que je procéderai oui ce serait
facile mais non je m'appelle neila
benzina à tous je suis tunisienne je
suis marié j'ai deux enfants je suis
chef d'entreprise est ce bientôt avoir
40 ans alors imaginez maintenant qu
ingrid stenson ce soit mohamed al
bagdadi recruteur pour le compte de
d'âge état islamique d'irak et du levant
mohamed al bagdadi qui cherche à attirer
dans sa sphère dans s'agirait de se
faire un très grand nombre de jeunes
désespérés et perdu en quête de repères
en quête de guide des jeunes oui des
centaines de milliers de jeunes qui se
retrouveraient piégée qui se
retrouveraient incapables de faire
marche arrière et revenir sur leurs pas
oui il sera en mesure de le faire pour
les transformer en bombe humaine
mohamed al bagdadi vous savez quoi il
n'a pas attendu pour le faire il le fait
déjà aujourd'hui massivement et de façon
incontrôlée internet et les médias
sociaux ont déchaîné toutes les passions
internet et les médias sociaux ont
permis une grande effervescence ont
permis une ébullition sans pareil
internet et les médias sociaux font
aujourd'hui l'objet de tous les
fantasmes mais aussi malheureusement
toutes les manipulations alors qu'en est
il vraiment on a beaucoup vanté le
pouvoir de twitter et de facebook dans
les mobilisations révolutionnaire
rappelez-vous la rapidité avec laquelle
tous ces messages
tous ces slogans étaient transmis
l'impact que tout cela avait sur nous
tous que ça nous inspire et ça nous
donnait du pouvoir on se sentait unis
solidaires face à l'adversaire en mesure
enfin de pouvoir changer les choses
oui on se sentait capable de changer les
choses notre destin nous appartenait
enfin oui tout ça était possible
sauf que l'on s'est rendu compte aussi
de la capacité des états de pouvoir
utiliser toutes ces données ces
informations pour leur propre compte et
dans leur propre intérêt
on s'est rendu compte pire encore et
plus grave encore de la capacité des
terroristes de tout poil oui c'est le
cas de le dire de tous poils de pouvoir
aussi avoir un accès illimité au monde
pour propager leurs théories fascisante
et nauséabonde pour manipuler animé tous
les réseaux djihadistes terroriste nord
trier sanguinaire oui il avait ainsi un
accès illimité au monde après l
enthousiasme qui a suivi le printemps
arabe ou ce que l'on aime à désigner
chez nous comme le début du printemps
tunisien après la place maïdan en
ukraine
on s'est mis à rêver qu enfin la parole
allait être redonner au peuple et que
ces peuples ces populations allaient en
faire bon usage
oui c'était possible on allait pouvoir
construire ensemble un monde meilleur
dans lequel on aurait plus de synergie
plus de collaboration plus de
possibilités plus d'opportunités
vous imaginez ce monde qu'ils étaient
capables de casser les barrières
d'abolir les frontières de nous
permettre de nous rapprocher et de
chercher réellement l'intérêt de tous
qui transcenderait les intérêts
individuels et individualiste c'était
enfin possible sauf que l'on s'est rendu
compte aussi malheureusement que les
usages de cette nouvelle liberté était
bien plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraissait
la démocratie
digital a du mal à se mettre en place le
chemin est encore bien long et difficile
oui lusage de cette nouvelle liberté
nous avait amené énormément de
déconvenues et ses déconvenues nous
pousse aujourd'hui malheureusement à
remettre en question ce modèle pseudo
libertaire c'est triste de le dire ce
dôme libertaire oui parce que finalement
in et libertaire que pour les
démocraties bien établie bien ancrées
les états autoritaires eux n'ont plus
rien à craindre de ces géants de
l'internet de ces acteurs de l'internet
de ces fous d'information qui d'ailleurs
il faut le souligner au passage sont
d'abord là pour du business sont d'abord
là pour une vocation mercantile ils sont
d'abord là pour monétiser et tirer de
l'argent de votre passage dans leur
environnement dans leur système
oui ils savent tirer de l'argent dès que
vous vous rapprochez de leur sphère
alors les états autoritaires n'ont plus
peur de tout ça parce qu'aujourd'hui ils
en maîtrisent complètement les modes de
fonctionnement regardez d'ailleurs
comment google a plié devant la chine
voyez comment la russie a exigé que ces
données soient stockées sur son
territoire regardez encore comment la
msa a fait en sorte de pouvoir avoir
accès à toutes les informations et à
toutes les données des gaffes à google
amazon facebook et apple et de bien
d'autres d'ailleurs et c'est alors
aujourd'hui où se pose la question
effectivement finalement est ce que tout
ceci n'est qu'un leurre les
gouvernements semblent maîtriser
complètement les modes de fonctionnement
de l'internet haut débit au nid du mal
ils ont eu du mal à maîtriser les outils
du web ils ont été pris du coup de court
par la déferlante du web
et puis depuis essentiellement ces
quatre cinq dernières années ils se sont
réorganisés ils ont investi massivement
pour reprendre le contrôle
et tous les contenus aujourd'hui qu'ils
soient écrits ou oraux sont surveillés
ils sont tous connus ils sont tous
maîtrisent
et la menace qui justifie une telle
surveillance est bien réelle sauf qu'il
ya un paradoxe en même temps que l'on a
vu se mettre en place cet arsenal et
cette puissance de contrôle on a vu au
final un manque de contrôle total les
dérives sont là et elles sont beaucoup
plus importantes qu'avant on a vu la
prolifération de toutes les utilisations
malibu malhonnête de l'internet de
toutes les utilisations malsaine la
cybercriminalité la fraude
le hacking à tout va oui on n'a jamais
autant surveillés autant contrôlés et on
n'a jamais perdu le contrôle autant
qu'en ce moment alors peut-être que ce
paradoxe s'explique aujourd'hui par
l'absence d'un cadre législatif qui soit
adéquat qui soit approprié qu'ils soient
bien configuré pour le monde de
l'internet
probablement qu'il ya une faille qui ne
porte pas dans ses gènes dans son adn
les possibilités de pouvoir agir
efficacement en amont et en aval
c'est comme si aujourd'hui dans la vraie
vie on avait des indicateurs un peu
partout des indics ce qu'on aimait
appeler chez nous des indics c'est
indique la nous observent vous regardent
ils voient des malfaiteurs en puissance
ils voient des des criminels préparé
leur coup ils voient des délinquants se
promener ils peuvent pas agir
ils peuvent juste les observer ne
peuvent pas les empêcher de commettre
leur crime ils peuvent pas les juger une
fois que les délits sont commis par
manque de police par manque de juges par
manque de 2 d'un cadre juridique et
judiciaire adaptée alors c'est
probablement aujourd'hui au gouvernement
de l'internet de prendre les devants et
de s'organiser par lui même
la régulation doit venir de l'intérieur
de ce gouvernement de l'intérieur de
l'internet c'est à lui de trouver les
solutions
c'est à lui d'aller chercher les
mécanismes qui vont lui permettre de
proposer un modèle dans lequel on aurait
tous les avantages de l'internet sans en
avoir les inconvénients
oui c'est possible sauf qu'il faut y
réfléchir
par exemple
on pourrait penser à une meilleure
identification des personnes à une
meilleure traçabilité des contenus cette
identification des personnes obligerait
tout un chacun à avancer à visage
découvert a assumé pleinement qui nous
sommes ce que nous écrivons ce que nous
disons ce que nous racontons parce que
imaginez que vous puissiez vous cacher
derrière des pseudonymes insulté à tout
va dire tout ce que vous voulez bien sûr
que vous allez en profiter
aujourd'hui ce que j'appelle c'est plus
de prise de responsabilité plus de
responsabilisation des internautes
évidemment cela n'est possible que si on
avance à visage découvert que si on est
obligé de nous dévoiler clairement est
entièrement pour pouvoir le faire
je propose une carte d'identité digital
une carte d'identité numérique
cette carte d'identité numérique
viendrait remplacer avantageusement tous
ces cookies qui aujourd'hui nous trace
et nous traquent déjà à notre insu alors
autant le faire ouvertement et en
l'assumant entièrement oui c'est
possible
cette carte d'identité serait un réel
atout pour le monde de l'internet
cette carte d'identité serait une
révolution pour le pour le modèle
internet
certains me diront et les droit à
l'oubli et la volonté d'anonymat
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait alors il faut y
réfléchir évidemment mais ce que je
pense que si on mettait les deux sur la
balance
moi je préférerais un modèle où
finalement chacun accepterait d'assumer
pleinement ce qu'il dit et ce qu'il
écrit je pense que ce modèle nous
proposerait le meilleur de ce qu'il ya
dans le monde virtuel
alors si je dois revenir à un green
stallman vous serez toujours en mesure
de faire connaissance avec elle et de et
d'aller voir qu'il ya derrière l'écran
par contre vous aurez grâce à cette
carte d'identité numérique la
possibilité d'aller checker d'aller
vérifier la véracité de ses propos
et ça ce serait un réel atout parce que
au moins vous serez pas en train de
discuter avec un barbu d'arrêt
l'écran de l'autre côté ingrid tasman
elle même serait probablement heureuse
de s'assurer que c'est bien vous qui
êtes de l'autre côté delà de la ligne
alors oui à la démocratie digital cette
démocratie digital qui a besoin encore
de plusieurs étapes pour se mettre en
place
parmi ces étapes je préconise cette
carte d'identité digital cette carte
d'identité numérique grâce à laquelle on
aurait un écosystème beaucoup plus sain
un écosystème beaucoup plus conscients
un ego un écosystème avec plus de
confiance
un écosystème qui profiterait à tout le
monde
merci